it's jimmy fallon
[Applause]
i love you wait the last time you were
here was there not an audience still it
was nose pre it was pre anything because
we've done the show a bunch of times but
i think is this the first time i'm back
with an audience yes exactly right so
his wife nan and i started flower films
our production company when i was 19. um
so try 28 years ago you dared my way i
dared your wife to start a production
company and i knocked it out of the park
and me and chris miller and jimmy and
then we all met on fever pitch and nan
and jimmy found love and got married and
had two kids
good luck
you're a very good luck for me
i i'm loving this show by the way it's
crushing everyone's good rust
i don't see him but maybe he's hiding
he's awesome he's fantastic the show's
great it's what you want in the morning
i want you i want your sunshine i want
your energy do you have like a ritual
before you go out every night what goes
through your mind before that curtain
opens can you bring us inside your head
and your heart or like what
what is it
before that curtain opens everything
butterflies it's it's excitement it uh
you know there's just
you get a quick touch-up of your makeup
you make sure your suits on then like
you hear the roots are playing there's a
curtain here and higgins it gets
announced he comes in it's like how many
seconds 20 seconds and the band's like
20 seconds then it's quiet then the band
kicks in you see the title and then
when i'm about to go out it's it the
light hits the curtain you can see the
circle and then it just fluffs out and
you're like all right and you go out and
it's like going
starting a race or going into the ring
or something where you're just like i
don't know if these jokes are funny this
is the first time i'm reading them there
was nothing on the page this morning my
amazing writers wrote all these jokes
today like as of this morning there's no
right now there's no monologue it gets
done in the afternoon well also because
you have to be current a lot of that
monologue for someone like me
the viewer is also getting information
and news i love that about opening
monologues not only are you getting
comedy but you are getting information
about what is going on in the world that
yeah yeah you are you shouldn't but yes
you are yeah you please read the news
and whatever and go to better outlets
but yes i used to do that when i was a
kid like with weekend update too that's
how i'd find out what's going on in the
world i go i don't know what's going on
in the world but i know now through you
know uh dennis miller you know i mean
weekend update is such a big influence
on the drew's news like because i grew
up loving weekend update and one of my
favorite iterations obviously is you and
tina fey
come on
we had such a good chemistry
it was like the uh the kid who didn't do
his homework and uh the smart girl
that's gonna give him the answers that's
kind of how our chemistry was like and
she was just so fun and i remember just
she would write these monologues like
for her like she'd write jokes for me
all the time but she wrote these
monologues for her that would just
destroy i mean like wiping your tears
and like oh my gosh can we give an emmy
every episode to this person
tina fey is a genius can i ask you a
personal question yeah um i think this
book because i've read all of the books
i have all the books we read all the
books me and the dart my two daughters
one of which is your wife's goddaughter
yeah um it started out with dada yeah it
did yeah it took off my baby's first
word says dada my favorite
mama everything is mama then this is
baby it was one where it's like a baby
body book like where's your nose where's
your eyes and stuff like that it's cute
and now it's nana but if nana loves you
more and you know why he loves you more
why billy jay
that was his line
if you said nancy's father if you said
bye billy jay i love you he would say
i love you more.
and i was like wow that's such a good
line i wish it was fun
and so i
yeah i know that yeah i love you more
you always said and so i want grandmas
and their grandkids to get in the room
they get the parents out there and let's
just go me and you knows make some
memories and they go uh and basically
the ideas is like what what do you love
uh and the grandma says whatever it is
you love i love you more than that so
you can think of anything in the world
like uh chocolate chocolate bar
fountains and like yeah i love you more
than that i love you more than wait hold
on
which one yeah there's only 10 pages
but they're all quality pages will you
read like two or three pages oh my gosh
because it i'm sorry it's the most
selling point of the book it's so good
uh more than the moon more than the
stars more than all of the planets by
far
uh more than paris and the eiffel tower
more than cats with super cat power
it's like this is weird i got to be
really creative with this one
it's so good you know what it is i i i
got a little weepy with this one too
because i like books that are a little
sad but not too sad
from from forever from one past 104
you'll always love nana but nana loves
you more because even when nana's not
around the love that you get from a
grandma you don't never forget if you're
lucky to get it it's the course
[Music]